how to get over the fear of public
speaking if you're an expert in your
field and you should be as an
entrepreneur then public speaking will
become a part of what you do you you
want to be the face of your company you
want to be able to promote yourself
properly how people be able to spread
your message and it's a part of your
responsibility is to be able to do great
media interviews and be able to do
presentations to spread your work I got
a great question from one of my readers
siddell who wrote in to say I need tips
to get over my fear of public speaking
and deliver a great presentation I know
it's scary anything you do for the first
time is scary especially when there's a
peep a group of people watching you and
you know there's an opportunity to fail
and suck and and worry about how people
are gonna think about you it's one thing
to fail on your own where nobody can see
but failing in public where people can
watch that's scary that adds a whole
other level to things that that makes it
a lot harder to get into but it is a
skill that you can learn just like
anything else and you can become a lot
more comfortable with it I remember one
of my presentations one of my first kind
of big presentations I was flown to
Brunei after I'd sold my software
company to help teach their young
entrepreneurs how to be successful as
entrepreneurs and I was shocked to find
out that it was a huge room there are
500 people there I was up on a big stage
and it was being broadcast nationally on
their television station I had done that
many presentations up to that point so I
was sweating bullets I was really
nervous but but what really helps me
through through that and through every
presentation it wasn't things like
imagine people in their underwear
imagine you talking to your family I
don't know I read a lot of this stuff
none of that helped me if that works for
you go for it but for me it didn't work
what helped me was number one
remembering why I'm doing this and this
isn't just for speaking this is for
anything that makes you nervous if you
are going into a sales call if you're
hiring your first employee whenever you
start something new that you haven't
done before you're gonna be a little
scared and nervous about it but remember
why you're doing is you're getting up on
stage to do a presentation why are you
there and it should be to help people
right if it's not to help people then
you shouldn't be doing
you're not gonna get a great result your
goal going up on stage and doing that
presentation is to help the audience
realize something to help them make a
change in their lives for the better so
it's a noble goal it's something that
you're up there to help you're not up
there to pitch or this Sal and I've
always found that helpful for me even
even not so much now but but when I
started my business I'm a chemical comm
I got nervous talking to big companies
you know Microsoft will call me and say
we want to work with you and it gets so
nervous before the call I call got a
call in an hour at Microsoft when we're
gonna say I don't look stupid I want to
I want to showcase my expertise and what
I'm talking about
hope you don't say the wrong thing I got
so nervous I built up this whole thing
in my head this block and I realized
like these guys I can help them I know I
could help them this isn't something
that that I'm not sure if I can do or
not I know I can help them I know I can
help them get results and so that calms
me and again this works for me I don't
know if it works for you but but it
works for me so I think about my
audience and I know I can help them
stand in front of this camera and
speaking to you guys it's a little less
nerve-wracking than being on stage but
but I do it more confidently because I
know I can help and that's my intention
it's not to sell you on my worksheets or
my website or my business or anything
it's to help you help answer this
question and so that can be a great goal
going in the second thing that I found
really useful for me is practice just
like any other skill you want to learn
you want to learn how to do something
you have to practice and you start small
and sometimes the end goal may be maybe
so big it may be so unattainable because
you don't know the steps to get there
and if you want to learn how to
snowboard you may look at some of the
great snowboarders and they're doing all
these tricks and flips and and you can't
even stand up on your board and you
think that's impossible I'm never gonna
get there right if you look at speakers
and you look at Tony Robbins or whoever
your favorite speaker is and you see how
great he is and and you think I'm never
gonna be like that and so you don't get
started because you're too afraid you
can be great but you have to start at
the beginning you start you start
sucking you start but you start
and you start getting better each time
you get better and better and better and
it may be at the beginning just doing it
in front of a camera we're just doing it
in front of the mirror I did so many
presentations as my practice just
talking to myself in the mirror that's
what I did and it helped it gave me
confidence that I'd gone through it a
couple times I knew what I was talking
about I got comfortable material more
and more my wear my jokes are gonna be
all of that and it made the presentation
better so talk to yourself in the mirror
record some of your videos
I'm new gonna play them back and think
they were terrible and you're gonna be
your own worst critic I still look back
on my first YouTube videos and think oh
my god these are so bad I should I
should remove them they're they're
really bad by my standards now but
people still like them and watch them
and it's fun to see that the progression
so I keep them up but record yourself
put it up start doing speaking at small
events so some of the first speaking of
gigs that I did were at the YMCA were at
my local city government they had these
workshops for entrepreneurs that I
delivered all of that helped and there
were small groups you know my first
presentation were three people who
showed up three people and then I had
five and then I had ten and then I had
20 and it started to grow and as you
start doing something and you achieve a
little bit of success you get some
confidence like if you can get to here
you thought getting here would be really
hard but you got there you did it now I
said I can do that I'm okay doing that
and now you can push yourself to go here
and then here and you slowly make your
way up and soon you're at the point
where you couldn't imagine that you
would get that far because you've gotten
so much practice you've gotten so much
better and you enjoy it so start start
small start talking to yourself start
making video start putting them up get
your practice do something every day if
your goal is to be a public speaker do
something every day to practice being a
public speaker and that could be going
to an advantage speaking or could be on
your own recording yourself in your in
your home in your office I used to get
nervous recording myself when there are
people around the first step was me
being nervous just in front of the
camera
and and I could say great when I wasn't
on camera but then I got the camera and
I started stuttering and
I'm you know my it's not making sense
but then I could get comfortable enough
to do it on my own but if somebody was
in the room with me I would panic you
know I would stumble I get nervous I
start sweating and it wouldn't it
wouldn't flow wouldn't come out now I
can do that and it's not a problem but
it just it comes to practice and each
time you get a little better and a
little butter and a little bitter like
any other muscle you build it up and you
get stronger so I know it's scary at the
start I know it can be overwhelming I
know there's a huge fear of making
yourself look stupid and and falling on
your face in front of in front of other
people right that's a huge fear but if
you can remember why you're doing this
and it's a noble goal and you want to
help people and and this is something
that you're set out to do and you
practice and practice and practice on
your own in front of the camera in front
of small audiences and you start to
build it up you'll get better and better
and better and you'll keep improving
your quality and you eventually get to
be the person that you looked up to if
it was 20 Roberts or whoever it is you
can get to that level to practice belief
for those of you watching if you like
the video please give it a thumbs up
below it always makes me want to do more
for you if you have a comment about this
video a tip you have and how to be a
good public speaker or if you have
another question for your business leave
it below I'm a good video response thank
you so much and I'll see you soon
you